[Musique]
en 1968 la préfecture de la seine a
délivré une seule autorisation de
circuler pour voitures hippomobiles
contre 250 milles environ pour voitures
automobiles
après un mois d enquête nous avons
retrouvé les derniers irréductibles au
progrès je me suis et madame charest y
marchand de fromages au marché de rully
[Musique]
fondé du temps des gaulois non c'est
vrai oui comme dans le temps on aimerait
bien avoir mon et on sait combien de
temps vous fait ce métier culot de jolis
de gueule puis la succession de lait par
an c'est-à-dire en 29 sept on ça peut
vivre trente ans mais à condition d'être
à la campagne et à paris nantes arrive
pas vite parler lui parler du robinet en
est par lui-même de à mon idée quand ils
arrivent vers les 18 ans 17 18 ans en
mai il commença le savez pourquoi saluer
se sont dits faciles salut face à face à
lui connu beaucoup tandis que sur la
terre à la campagne la bête est fait
pour aller sur la terre n'est pas sûr du
pavillon qui sont toujours pas la
chaleur résonnent dans la mettre dans la
tête les hongrois réponse aux nombreux
noms latins colis et des encombrants qui
en est pas vous avez ça ça me dérange
pas du tout qu'il y ait des milliers de
voitures dont il n'est pas content et ça
me fait absolument rien du tout ça n'est
pas plus d'effet que dirait pas du tout
la même
est-ce que six ans qu'est ce qu'elle
fera justement le jamais d'accident
j'avais des crises intestines beast a je
suis par lui avec les automobilistes
il passe au noir pas se leurrer ce qui
garde toujours grâce à brad pitt tient
toujours à droite de façon correcte mais
je suis pas ennuyé du tout du tout du
tout vous voyez avec un cheval je
marcherai même mieux dans paris avec un
chemin il ira mieux qu'avec une auto
save et font réellement avoir l'habitude
des bêtes
et puis aimé les animaux comme ma femme
et moi nous les mots pour avoir laissé
tout le temps avec un choix les
personnes qui voudront à l'heure
actuelle conduira les vins du rejet par
continent paris il n'entrait plus
maintenant des seaux d'eau mais ici dans
paris
g je ne crois pas vous trouverez un
choix à la pauvre con propre pourtant
porte de pantin
ce sont encore des chevaux qui
conduisent les taureaux nous avons ainsi
retrouver les derniers pensionnaires du
marché aux bestiaux
[Musique]
placez la au père pendant quelques mois
ils sont engraissés moyennant un travail
quotidien peu harassant avant de partir
pour les abattoirs de vaugirard
abandonnant au coin des rues elles leurs
carrioles désormais inutile
et comment achetons un seul blog acheter
ou aux abattoirs de vous dire à vous
donner mon c koi de la voix nous lui
donnons de la one du son et puis de la
bonne dizaine que c'est une vingtaine
qui travaillent un peu alors il faut la
nourrir quand même avec certaines
restrictions il faut pas trop la poussée
façon voulu pallier a tenté un coup de
sang dessert là ça vous coûte cher un
cheval non pas très cher son nom revient
à peu près ici je n'achète jamais de
paille parce que je m'en aille chercher
en gare un cheval revient donc avec
l'assurance a380 par jour alors que sens
rouler la voiture la plus économique
coûte déjà la première année 5 francs 80
jours mais qu'un choix je vous allez
aussi bien qu'avec une auto et même de
la façon que je conduis moi [ __ ] ça ne
doit déranger rien du tout tout le
contraire
je passerai où c'est qu'une auto ne
passera pas du moment que je serais
passé la tête du cheval le récent il
arrivera même jour le derrière de la
voiture vient paraît est ce que c'est
votre permis de conduire à j'ai mon
permis de conduire gecol permis de
conduire auto et moto mais jamais au
moral et vous avez une voiture mais j'ai
acheté un camion
or le camion ça jette je suis tombé
malade j'ai perdu un set au mes qui doit
faire l'un je suis tombé malade et puis
après j'ai voulu mettre un camion lourd
ça ne marchait pas ça m'a mis en colère
est vraiment lieu des faits comme une
espèce de dépression nerveuse
[Musique]